and madison in 48 hours allegiant
stadium will be rocking for that monday
night football and the raiders 2021
season debut this is after six weeks of
training six weeks rather of training
camp the team says they can't wait for
kickoff john treach has a preview john
finally it's raiders and ravens on
monday night football
it's only saturday come on we've counted
down until the third downs and tackling
sounds amplify in las vegas atmosphere
of 65 thousand raucous people it will be
historic it just needs to get here
playing in the nfl in front of a rowdy
crowd and performing on a las vegas big
stage will be a new experience for a lot
of players but john gruden is adequately
confident in his crew especially the new
offensive lineman many of the players
are new starters for the silver and
black but they have a big game pedigree
that dates back to their college days
like when they played at alabama and
clemson game day can't come soon enough
i think alex leatherwood's been trained
pretty good to play in front of big
crowds he's two-time national champion
andre james is in his third year john
simpson's been in a big arena his whole
life so these guys are anxious to start
forming their own identity and they
realize they have big shoes to fill and
i think they're confident
that they can come together and be a
good unit
and we have thoroughly assessed this
first game it will be the first regular
season game in front of fans in las
vegas history as you know we have no
idea how this is going to go down but
that is what makes it fun for all of us
48 hours and counting